quelle est la volonté de samsung avec
ces nouveaux modèles s10 s10 plus on est
dans une continuité du s9 on va vraiment
cherché à apporter de nouvelles
innovations notamment pour se
positionner peut-être sur un marché qui
est de plus en plus exigeants l'a fait
en fait ça me saoule
[Musique]
à en arriver à londres hôtel de karting
en plein centre de londres
aujourd'hui on est là pour le pack de
samsung pour voir les nouveaux
smartphones galaxy s 10 s10 plus s10e
est probablement le samsung galaxy f
j'ai la chance d'avoir été invité par 1
500 merci samsung pour aller voir cet
event
je suis très impatient suis très content
et en plus de ça il devrait y avoir
d'autres annoncent une monde connecté il
devrait y avoir des petits écouteurs
intra auriculaires et il devrait
probablement y avoir le smartphone à
écran pliable de samsung autant vous
dire qu'aujourd'hui il va y avoir plein
d'annoncés mais juste avant tout à faire
un petit tour parce que cet hôtel est
juste ouf estime le curtain dans londres
regardez-moi ça l espèce de truc juste
dingue j'ai deux grands lits à 140 je
sais pas du tout ce que je vais en faire
j'ai ici de ce côté là un espèce de
canapés chesterfield coupée en deux en
plus de ça j'ai même une enceinte
marshall qui est juste dingue et la
grande est plutôt pas mal c'est qu'ils
ont même pas du tout lésiné sur le mini
bar attention quand même l'abus d'alcool
est dangereux pour la santé
donc à ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on ait faire déjà un petit tour dans
londres histoire d'eau de s'oxygéner
avant d'attaquer level qui à mon avis va
être juste énorme
et je pense pas que ce soit fait exprès
mais c'est très drôle parce que la télé
de ma chambre c'est une samsung comme
quoi des fois le hasard fait bien les
choses
ça c'est sage dans la nuit je suis
franchement super mal alors on va
choisir le lit un plouf plouf ce sera
toi où je dormirai ce soit ok mais avec
ça va ça se passe comme tu veux mais où
elle demandé l'autorisation pour filmer
non c'est fait dégager et pas loin de
films et on s'est dit qu'on allait quand
même filmé dans la piscine directement
la voilà comme ça en filmant des biens
et la quant à elle fait les belles
photos sans retrouver sont au programme
regardez regardez moi cette pause donc
là on coupe le cam avec quentin dans la
partie à leur pack 2 d'ici quelques
instants et les agrégats qu'est ce qu'on
va avoir comme smartphone aujourd'hui
normalement dans l'a4 non 4,5
peut-être même plus ce n'est pas que des
smartphones a well as we pas que des
smartphones chabal en produits mais moi
j'ai produit mon smartphone
ouais en smartphones en à 404 qui ne pas
encore donc là on en croit on à après
une montre on a un bracelet on a des
écouteurs on a plein de trucs oui
[Musique]
mais cela ce film mais ça n'arrête pas
les photos si ça n'arrête pas les photos
bien sûr j'ai depuis deux mois permanent
aux mines cassette j'aime une cassette
dans ma vie hs et voilà elle afin
d'arriver à paul harry potter ou pas ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que barbara mon
travail c'est samsung n'a absolument
jamais regarder harry potter 6 mars au
championnat c'est quand même la loose
les débits 10 fois jamais vu harry
potter
et
[Musique]
ce n'est pas au niveau de l'éclairage
des coûts très bien je passais la
conférence comme ça ça va être
on est prêt pour le pack de l'arrivée
terminé avec une migraine autre quasi
qui est ce on est hyper éclairant
d'aller plus d'éclairer du public du
soir
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
moi
et
on est alan pack de samsung autant
présenter les nouveaux samsung galaxy s
10 s10 plus s10e es10 + 5 g le galaxy
folle enfin plein de trucs qui a eu des
bugs gênants 2 monde peut y tracer les
annonces de deuil alors annonces
majeures déjà sur le galaxy folk enfin
depuis très longtemps
le premier smartphone à écran pliable de
samsung ça je n'en parlerais le terrien
parce que c'est vraiment un sujet hyper
intéressant il ya plein de choses à dire
on en reparle prochainement abonnez vous
restez connectés on verra ça d'ici
quelques jours probablement demain pour
parler déjà ds 10 et 10 pouces et s10e
il faut vraiment voir la gamme comme
ayant esquissé ce disque plus en
connaissez déjà la gamme avec notamment
les chutes ainsi plus et cela fait plus
s17 10 plus c'est très logique
ils se disent eux on n'est pas dans une
stratégie comme apple c'est à dire avoir
un smartphone qui vient se positionner
dans le milieu de gamme un peu plus
abordable un peu moins cher un peu moins
speaking tout aussi intéressant donc ça
c'est vraiment cool
les grosses innovations à retenir si
vous voulez au niveau de ses smartphones
savait déjà
je dirais le capteur d'empreinte
digitale est situé directement sous
l'écran ça c'est vachement cool capteur
d'empreintes digitales l'ultrason qui
n'a pas craindre ce que votre doigt et
humide zavadil verrouillé dans toutes
les circonstances un avis de ces
pratiques c'est sécurisé et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant hautement qui est
intéressant c'est au niveau de la caméra
triple module photo à l'arrière du
smartphone ça c'est plutôt cool vous
avez un tel objectif
vous allez avoir une caméra principale
ou avoir un terrain très grand temps que
tu auras 123° autre point qui est
vraiment novateur c'est le fait d'avoir
du hdr
dix plus notamment au niveau du galaxy s
10 plus justement vous allez pouvoir
filmer en 4k l'uhd sur la canne à la
principale vous allez pouvoir du
traitement avec adobe premiere une
version spéciale justement pour votre os
samsung galaxy s est vraiment
intéressant il ya toutes ces parties là
mais je le développe change de lieu
c'est ça que j'aime on n'a pas le droit
de filmer mais on sentait caméra à la
main ça va les oreilles les forêts ici
il aurait aimé un fait normal
on était là où on l'est donc avec
matignon on a eu tout à l'heure la
conférence de la présentation de très
nombreux produits très nombreux
smartphones parsons où c'était un peu un
florilège devant ce soir tout à fait
qu'on a vraiment annoncé énormément de
produits une belle gamme kindle
alors pour recentrer maths il travaille
chez samsung
toi tu t'occupes des produits autant de
dire que la hat est carrément calais tue
c'est carrément quoi nous dire c'est un
peu tombé en fait notamment les
smartphones notamment les 500 soit en
allant y avait pas mal d'années ce soir
s dix églises plus est 10e
on va garder de côté un petit peu le
galaxy folle vous a fait on regarde un
petit peu en guest pour plus tard on
n'en parle plus tard donc alors on peut
toujours commencer par les dix se disent
plus si ça te convient pour relever ce
10 août obtenu peu à part où tout à fait
ok alors quelle est la volonté de
samsung avec ces nouveaux modèles s10
s10 plus on est dans une continuité du
s9 on va pas avoir cherché à apporter de
nouvelles innovations notamment pour se
positionner peut-être sur un marché qui
est de plus en plus exigeants l'a fait
en fait ça me semble vraiment répondre à
tous les besoins
si celui ci pour ça qu'il sort cette
année dont trois références es10 es12
plus vraiment la volonté de samsung
c'est un monde doit répondre à tous ces
consommateurs auxquels toujours un
smartphone qui exigent au niveau de
l'écran multimédia
il ya un usage était important j'imagine
des caméras on va encore plus loin
alors pour allier les deux justement
caméra écran on a une petite goutte
d'appel passant quand je sais c'est un
tout petit duel à une petite bulle une
petite bulle de rêve tout est alors une
bulle petite bulle sur le s10 adéquat
une société bull je trouve assez
intéressante sur les 10 plus fiable plus
mitigé clcc ça prend un peu plus de
place
soit je ne suis pas encore habitué c'est
un peu un symétrique en fait tu vois
bien ce cas c'est bizarre et assez gros
soit côté
assez gros après c'est comme par exemple
quand tu prends ton téléphone dont dans
ce sens là donc ça ici ta petite bulle
ouais donc ici quand tu alain clean
comme ça quand tu regarde des vidéos en
fait c'est pas du tout dérangé parce que
ceux du régime
ouais ça devient admissible c'est pas du
tout dans ta zone à dans ta zone de
regard ok donc elle est vraiment
transparente et puis ces deux petites
ses deux capteurs ont vraiment un
intérêt notamment pour la photo oui pour
tout ce qui est mode portrait pour avoir
cet éphèbe ok donc ça prend vraiment
tout son sens et c'est très mode bouquet
du coup en caméra celle fillon le film
océans quatre cailloux jetés alors tout
à fait c'est une nouveauté également on
va retrouver le duel pixels qui
maintenant donc bien sûr la caméra
frontale donc ça c'est vraiment la
nouveauté de cette gamme asus alors
l'intérêt de ce smartphone sdis disent
plus sur les bus en tout cas c'est quoi
c'est quoi l'adn du produit est ce que
c'est ce qu'on recherche un smartphone
polyvalent dans le haut de gamme ou est
ce qu'on veut vraiment faire un focus
sur la photo et au gros focus avec le s9
caméra ouverture variable c'est quoi
l'idée là c'est quoi la donne de ce
produit offre là vraiment c'est ce
produit là en fait c'est vraiment la
quintessence à la quintessence de
samsung du savoir-faire way est vraiment
sur ce produit on va retrouver trois
piliers à trois piliers forts qui sont
les tran voilà donc ce nouvel écran
infiniti qui maintenant comme vous
pouvez le voir reprendre 94 % de la
surface d'affichage
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup juste pour
vous donner un petit ordre d'idée par
exemple sur le galaxy s donc le premier
du nom ouais on a multiplié donc la
surface d'affichage par 2,6 donc on
partait de loin quand même
on partait de l'an passé mais maintenant
on arrive à un résultat qui est vraiment
qui est vraiment camille est donc là en
terme de confort déjà donc on à 94% la
surface d'affichage ce qui est énorme
également en termes de technologie donc
là on est sur la technologie dynamic
amoled qu'est ce que c'est donc c'est du
super amoled avec en plus la norme
plus d'accord pour vraiment avoir une
qualité d'image impressionnante et
immersive est-ce qu'on va s'en rendre
compte moelle usage de cette vraiment de
cette différence est ce que ces deux
sources des contenus peut-être un peu
plus exigeants sont un peu plus de
définition ça va être notamment sur les
films etc
mais du coup je t'invite à le tester à
huy socialement pour habiller rosières
question ambiance avec grand plaisir
on a aussi une version 5 j'ai tout à
fait donc là c'est une version sans
bière et bradant un temps deux d'accord
les raisons en france seront développés
parce qu'encore l'instant les réseaux ne
sont pas encore sont pas encore prêts
une version 128 go de stockage du
rossini version qui va coûter jusqu'à 1
tera intérêts et demi avec une carte
micro sd c'est ça c'est énorme c'est
énorme et donc c'est l'édition aux
performances donc il ya vraiment le
summum de la terre ferme le temps de la
performance comme son nom l'indiqué
toile cette version qu'est ce qu'elle a
à la plusieurs choses donc déjà en
termes de stockage dont elle sera
disponible en 500 12 giga également un
terrain d'accord et ensuite au niveau de
la ram aussi donc là ça aide vraiment
mon édition puissante donc il va y avoir
8 gigas de ram pour la version 120 pour
la version 128 par donc aux 12 giga de
ram pour la version pour la version un
terrain ça va pour ce ça va avancer donc
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
s'adresse qui s'adresse augagneur parce
qu'on sait maintenant qui à peu près en
joueurs sur deux qui joue sur smartphone
donc oui c'est vraiment une volonté
d'avoir des smartphones puissants et
ensuite pour revient donc à cette
édition d'art commence donc la troisième
à spécificité donc ça va être au niveau
au niveau du matériau on va être sûr du
sac alors pourquoi mettre du sel 1
mickaël poste du lait ainsi pour
raconter un peu différente premium pour
quel coût alors c'est quoi cette idée
justement d'aller ciblé le gamer c'est
parce qu'on sent qu'il ya une segment
qui se développe de plus en plus et il
faut le prendre la peine de plus en plus
de gens jouent sur smartphone du mois
mais si on doit toujours répondre aux
besoins des consommateurs et du cou et à
la danse ok donc haut de gamme très haut
de gamme
s17 10 plus on peut parler un peu du à
10 e mais on peut l'appeler commence de
smartphones
c'est un smartphone haut de gamme mairie
un peu moins c'est l'essentiel en fait
l'essentiel et l'essentiel
essentiellement comme son nom l'indiqué
donc essentiel donc il va droit à
l'essentiel
on a un écran plat il n'y a pas d'écran
incurvé dessus on a néanmoins l'écran
super web dynamiques et voilà merci
beaucoup
une caméra de cellfish une caméra triple
caméra meilleur non double caméra région
avec kader arif oublie donc un capteur
de principe avec l'ouverture
ouais et ensuite on va retrouver du
tagant l'ultra grand oncle qui rêve est
une nouveauté sur le guen s peut donc
permettre en fait de fait de faire des
photos à 123 degrés qui donc on sait
similaire à peu près à la violence pas
de tels objectifs en ce lieu non pas
deux fois je le poke et donc donc
mégapixels suis là bas ok très bien en
termes de qualité de visionnage de
vidéos n'est sensiblement sur la même
chose sauf que l'écran n'est pas durable
c'est la même
les performances forcément la même chose
le stockage pareil top
ok la différence de cibles public un peu
plus jeune peut-être oui ok bon alors
c'est quoi du coup ça me saoule en 2019
samsung en 2010 c'est beaucoup
d'innovations ce que tu as pu le voir
avec la
avec la conférence c'était faux a dit
beaucoup de sorties que ça soit sur les
voyages sur le fold way beaucoup de
beaucoup de choses en 2019 et c'est très
bien une belle gamme qui va répondre à
tous les besoins
c'est assez hallucinant de nouvelles
mans connecter tout à fait une plusieurs
bennes plus pour le snop même temps dire
3 de ce qu'elle fit le hockey ça marche
et donc aussi les petits bugs doutes et
ils doivent être engagées que jamais
donc j'ai également bleus ces écouteurs
sans fil donc seront offerts pour toute
pré-commande du galaxy s 10 ou d'une s10
plus d'accord mais à partir
d'aujourd'hui du 20 février jusqu'au a
jusqu'au m6 je commande sur le site de
samsung normes et thibaut faire élire
sera exactement là mais sa fille et si
je mets les achats la guitare je peux
les avoir non seulement voter comme un
grand qu'est ce qu'on souhaite à 500
pour 2019 plein de réussite dans vos
projets j'imagine de nouvelles surprises
pour cette année j'imagine peut-être
jamais on n'en sait pas plus cool merci
beaucoup
alors vous avez plein de nouveautés au
niveau de l'intelligence artificielle
des photos qui vont les plus loin des
photos nuit toujours plus intéressant
plus performante d'une machine learning
spartak venir à prendre avec toutes les
photos qui vont être faits dans le monde
entier sur ses smartphones dont des
qualités photos qui vont s'améliorer de
jour en jour côté performance a toujours
un exynos 9820 dans le monde entier et
pour les usa et le canada s'installera
gones 855 un smartphone qui se recharge
sans fil et point qui est intéressant
que samsung nous a présenté que huawei a
fait y'a pas longtemps avec un sommeil
20 pro là ils le font avec ses
smartphones là c'est une recherche
inversée en gros 20 smartphones il a
plein de recharge vous avez besoin de
recharger vos petits bugs de recharger
le 1er smartphone ce que voulez vous
allez activer le mode vous le
positionner contre sa charge c'est cool
c'est pratique c'est rapide certains
terrestre bon vous l'aurez compris c'est
les smartphones que je trouve moi hyper
intéressant je t'emmène vidal celis
personnes le sont vraiment hyper cool
hyper intéressant parce que pourquoi
c'est intéressant qu'est ce qu'on voit
qu est ce qui nous qu'est-ce que ça va
nous apporter en réalité ces nouveaux
smartphones alors il ya l'innovation ça
avance a toujours plus ou moins en tout
cas ce qu'on voit est ce qui est
vraiment passionnant c'est que samsung
tient vraiment compte de ce qui se passe
en face à la concurrence sans voix c'est
clair
intégrer de nouvelles techno et
notamment au niveau de la photo ç'a
toujours été redonnés à samsung jour des
appareils photos très bon sur leur
smartphone déroge pas à la règle
le s9 s9 plus note 9 déjà excellent avec
notamment la caméra ouverture variable
et même les anciens modèles étaient déjà
très très bon mais on voit que avec une
concurrence chinoise qui est plus en
plus pressantes des techno même au
niveau du pixel 3 pixels 3xl a dû google
et non les états unis des techno en
termes de photos nuit de traitement
logiciel qui sont incroyables on voit
que ça fasse un petit peu samsung à
aller dans ses retranchements il est
déjà excellent en termes de photos en
termes de techno ils sont obligés de
continuer à être dans la course 2 bacs
pour avoir les meilleurs techno les
meilleures innovations pour plaire aux
consommateurs et pour au final entre un
consommateur a un budget et se dit voilà
moi j'ai tel budget je veux ce qui se
fait de mieux pour on pense toujours
systématiquement à samsung est sacrément
intéressant alors je sais pas ce que
vous en pensez
comment vous les trouvez ces smartphones
et se disent elles se disent plus s10e
on parlera du fol dans quelques jours
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire moi je trouve ça vraiment
hyper intéressant hyper cool hyper
prometteur j'ai hâte de les tester
plus en détails pour l'instant j'en ai
un là je vais rentrer demain matin donc
je vois un petit peu le tester il
découvert cette nuit comment il faut
bien se coucher du claé déjà 1h15 du
matin falloir monter la vidéo pour
qu'elle soit en ligne d'ici moins de six
heures autant vous dire que je fais
passer très peu de temps final avant
d'occuper dites moi ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires que je vous
hais ce soir on enfin très rapidement et
on les testerins dès qu'ils sortiront à
bientôt pour les 60 ans